wenn die regeln so sind wie sie sind und
auch wenn wir die regel überhaupt nicht
gefallen muss sich doch sie akzeptieren
um meine konsequenzen daraus ziehen
services kids und herzlich willkommen zu
einem neuen video in dem ich heute mal
mit euch gerne über ein thema reden
möchte was ja leider aktuell ist das
machen wir das oder schlecht finden es
besonders aktuell am heutigen tage oder
26 05 es ist das leidige aber doch
irgendwie unterhaltsame thema aviv und
ich sie auch gerade dass ich in der
festival überhaupt gar nicht drin das
muss mal kurz korrigieren wir spielen
gerade intern auf timo ja für alle die
das noch nicht erkannt haben und ich
muss glaube ich geringen dringend
dringend ein bisschen den sound weiter
machen 60 prozent
das kind mit mir ab kann ich den 260
prozent einstellen ok tut mir leid heute
was ich euch als erstes mal sagen möchte
ist wie gesagt das thema hat eine hohe
relevanz so tief ist ja eigentlich immer
aktuell es gibt immer irgendwelche
gründe sich zu streiten
und da kommen wir auch zum allerersten
punkt den ich gern zu dem thema machen
möchte tief an sich ist unnötig ja also
das braucht man nicht wirklich man muss
nicht zum selbstzweck anderen irgendwie
stress machen das leben schwierig machen
dass es einfach bullshit
das muss nicht sein was aber sehr wohl
sein muss ist das stehen zu den eigenen
fehlern
die meisten von euch werden vielleicht
wissen worum es geht wo es über dabei
geht bei dem thema und warum das thema
ausgerechnet heute angesprochen wird um
ausgerechnet dieses video das heute
kommt es gibt ja diese geschichte da ich
weiß gar nicht ob ich jetzt sehr darauf
eingehen will ich möchte auch nicht
irgendwie den eindruck erwecken dass es
irgendwie klicks kairo oder so möchte
einfach nur meine meinung zu dem thema
sagen damit ihr wisst wie ich da stehe
weil manche ja denken dass ich irgendwie
beef mit crafting pad hätte das ist
übrigens nicht der fall
für alle die das glauben also da müsst
euch keine sorgen machen da
von meiner seite aus besteht da keinen
beef aber ich habe natürlich auch die
geschichte gehört auch bevor justin
jetzt öffentlich gemacht habe falls ihr
noch nicht kennt schaut mal auf justins
kanal vorbei dazu ein video gemacht
dazu muss man jetzt sagen okay justin
ist natürlich sehr sehr ist ein cooler
typ so weit ich ihn kennengelernt habe
das team macht sowas aber auch gerne
also der macht gerne so ein bisschen
naja man kann also man wie gesagt dass
jetzt am besten was ich sagen will also
justin ist dann ist dann ganz direkt ist
habe ich so kennenlernen das ist ein
sehr direkter typ ist wenn irgendwas
stört dann spricht das halt sofort an
und zwar das jetzt auch in diesem fall
gemacht
ich möchte auch mal vorneweg sagen dass
zwischen mir und pat wie gesagt aber
steht kein beef oder so also da will ich
wieder da bin ich die leute beruhigen
die da glauben da geht es irgendwie
stress oder so da habe ich teilweise
gelesen ich musste habe ich noch
bisschen leiser machen dass leute meinen
ja ich dachte zwischen die am pad ist
alles cool es hat also in beef oder so
dies ist nicht der fall möchte auch gar
nicht so sehr jetzt bezug auf
irgendwelche namen nehmen weil das ist
auch irgendwie unsinnig als allererstes
mal leute ich hab heute eine richtig
richtig heftige klausur geschrieben ist
jetzt endlich hinter mir das war ein
richtig großer brocken makroökonomie
heißt das gute ding also jetzt erledigt
das war heavy und jetzt habe ich wieder
ein bisschen mehr zeit so zeit videos zu
machen und deswegen kommt doch heute
dieses video
ich hoffe dass das ding jetzt hier nicht
abstürzt ich bin übrigens wieder neu mit
einer der besten nicknames dafür mal ich
dir ja auch dass diese coole nicknames
haben aber ja jetzt zurück zum thema
visa brief an sich ist unnötig also es
gibt einfach keinen grund dafür anderen
das leben schwer zu machen das muss
wirklich nicht sein auch im allgemeinen
glaube ich das
so negative energie ist einfach keinen
sinn das klingt jetzt bisschen
esoterisch bisschen ja ja wie kann man
zum schreiben esoterische sei nicht das
richtige wort dafür also ich ja ich bin
ein gewissermaßen würde mich selbst
abgesehen aber ich glaube einfach dass
es bringt einem einfachen nicht sich so
sehr mit solchen themen zu beschäftigen
oder viel über leute nachzudenken die
man irgendwie nicht ab kann oder bi
streit das zieht einfach jeden rot alles
runter wenn ihr jetzt irgendwelche leute
erhält dann macht das euch irgendwie
auch betroffen darüber dass das nimmt
euch im mittelfeld euch dann irgendwie
schlecht
so geht es mir zumindest und darüber
hinaus natürlich auch noch der person
die ihr dann irgendwie angreift also ist
eigentlich für alle ein verlust deswegen
sehe ich da prinzipiell keinen sinn drin
wo bin ich aber sehr ist wie gesagt dass
leute zu ihren fehlern stehen und dass
sich die leute die mich angreifen
nämlich als erstes mal den ja ohne frist
ist der frist jetzt fiel mir ein
bisschen zeit wegnehmen
okay es bringt ja nichts so habe ich
jetzt einen kompass an asset managers
plate changes kate perfekt
worin ich aber sind sie jetzt hab ich
dir nochmal gesagt ich möchte noch mal
sagen leute dass man zu seinen fehlern
steht wie gesagt das finde ich wichtig
auch im sinne der fairness
bezogen auf die vario regelung heißt das
konkret oder im auf regeln im
allgemeinen wenn man einen fehler macht
dann ist es wichtig dazu zu stehen auch
damit man sich selbst gegenüber ehrlich
ist es auch eine wichtige sache
ehrlichkeit sich selbst gegenüber ist
ein thema was viele menschen gar nicht
so gar nicht so bewusst haben glaube ich
an über das viele viele menschen gar
nicht selbst nachdenken aber das ist
extrem wichtig wir mit euch selbst
umgeht ist extrem wichtig weil wenn ihr
wenn ihr euch selbst bemüht dann kann
das durchaus sein dass sie dann daran
noch monatelang zerrt und dadurch das
fertig macht deswegen möglichst ehrlich
mit sich sein
auch wenn es manchmal weh tut in dem
konkreten fall heißt das dass wenn man
fehler macht und irgendwelche regeln
bricht die auch für andere gelten
und nachdem man andere auch mist dann
muss man auch einfach zudem rede wo
stehen sie ja was soll ich glaube das
ist so und so muss das auch sein beitrag
ok kommen dahin bleibt mir fern vom
label so scheiße hier könnte eine kopf
bewegen
habs labs sein okay gibt dann lief ihr
euch mal ich kenne bisschen die zeit ab
wiese also diese regeln sind schon hart
finde ich persönlich also das ist schon
hart zu sagen ja wenn einem jetzt die
aufnahme crashte oder so und man hat
über die datei nicht mehr
dann wird das komplette inventar reset
also ich weiss nicht findet ihr sowas
hart oder angemessen schreibt das gerne
mal in die kommentare ich finde das ist
eine relativ harte regelung aber es ist
nunmal regel und nach der regel werden
alle bemessen und dementsprechend muss
man wenn man die regeln bricht auch
einfach ehrlich sein wie gesagt das tut
in dem moment sicher wie man denkt
sicher scheiße man könnte wahrscheinlich
selbst mehr als einmal in die faust oder
regt sich richtig auf dafür darüber dass
diese regel so ist wie sie ist aber es
ist nun mal so wenn man damit spielt
muss man eben auch dazu stehen dass man
eventuell eine regel gebrochen hat auch
wenn das einem in dem moment sinnlos
erscheint und man sich aufregen seid ja
warum denn so ein scheiß regeln so wie
sie jetzt nicht mein urteil sondern das
könnte man sich denken im moment ja es
ist eben wichtig dann zu sagen okay wäre
es jetzt im anderen so gegangen und er
wäre deswegen ausgeflogen wie würde ich
mich dann fühlen das ist eine wichtige
frage die man sich stellen muss
also man sollte andere prinzipiell nur
so behandeln wie man selbst behandelt
werden will dass die goldene regel die
ist ganz einfach aber ich auch ganz ganz
schwierig anzuwenden weil klar
man würde wahrscheinlich vielleicht dem
thema dem anderen sagen der die regel
gebrochen hat ja okay da muss ja zu mir
raus fliegen oder soll wenn man selbst
dran ist
da der mann sich scheiße deswegen jetzt
wirklich ist eine doofe sache aber man
muss wie gesagt man sollte
die regeln die man für andere anlegt
auch für sich selbst anlegen
das ist eine frage der fairness und es
einfach das kann man auch irgendwo
erwarten
konkret heißt das jetzt auf den fall den
flächenkauf mitbekommen haben auf den
ich mich hier so ein bisschen beziehe
was mich bis hin dazu beschäftigt dass
wir jetzt die richtung zu bringen heißt
das wenn die regeln so sind wie sie sind
und auch wenn wir die regel überhaupt
nicht gefallen muss sich doch sie
akzeptieren um meine konsequenzen daraus
ziehen
wenn ich regelbrüche werde weil das auch
für alle anderen gelten würde
für alle anderen das ist ein bisschen
mein standpunkt zu dem thema
ich freue mich übrigens leute das wollte
ich auch noch mal gesagt haben dass ich
jetzt wieder ein bisschen mehr zeit pro
ist der hier gegen mich immer 18
sekunden zeit stetig müssen die mitte
auf ok ok nice als ob ich jetzt an zeit
fucking ich werde locker inside man mal
sterben
nein nein nein nein nein nein nein nein
nein nein
doch nicht euer ernst
und eigentlich bin ich jetzt wirklich
glaube ich habe aber einen punkt so weit
drüber gebracht dass man sich wenn man
erwartet dass andere bestraft werden für
regelbrüche auch selbst an regeln halten
muss und die konsequenzen aus regel
brechen ziehen muss das ist mein
standpunkt zu dem thema so ein bisschen
so als einstieg in die täglichen videos
die ab heute wieder kommen sollen
soweit ich den zeit habe ja ich bin
gespannt auf eure meinung schreibt man
die gerne mal in die kommentare
wir sind zum nächsten video wieder haut
rein macht es gut und